The Joe Rogan experience,
I remember the first time I got caught speeding.
I was 16 and I just didn't have the money.
So I thought if I broke down in tears,
the copper,
no,
of course he just fucking farming.
And the worst thing is
my brother is a cop and he reported it to my brother and then my brother teased
me in the near future.
My brother used to do awful things as my brother.
My brother's named Denny nugent and I think that's a bad site.
He's a member of the rod squad now.
And uh,
I got,
I was driving home and it's a 17,
which is still not the legal age to drink in Australia.
And I'm driving home and I had two beers now.
I would have been under the limit,
but still,
I'm not even allowed to have two beers in me because I'm 17.
Right.
I get pulled up,
I get breathalyzed.
The guy goes,
please breathe into the tube.
And I said,
my brother was a sergeant at that stage.
And I was like,
okay,
go,
you know,
uh,
denny nugent had nugent does a
right and that you guys know,
I never heard of him.
Right.
So he goes off to his vehicle,
is there for like 15 minutes.
I'm just sitting in the car,
just panicking now he comes back out and he goes,
step out of the vehicle or was there a problem?
Anything over just step out of the vehicle right now.
So step out,
he cuffs me and smacks me under the bonnet of the car.
Right.
And I thought,
oh Jesus Christ,
fuck,
fuck.
Like this.
Right.
And then I and my brother laugh
being on the radio,
like he's actually gone back to his car radio station,
talked to my brother and he said,
scare the shit out of him,
you know what I mean?
Because it's cops and they go,
I was just joking with you.
I'm wiping tears away from where I was like,
good job guys.
Well done.
Thanks.
Hunting is just doing the same thing but on a,
on a more base level.
Just on a smaller level
in a way.
Yeah,
you're just doing it.
I mean,
you cutting out the middleman and you're cutting out,
you cut out the middleman and the animals live in completely wild.
This is like a concept behind hunting that certain types of people do.
It's called fair chase,
and what that means is that you're not dealing with a fenced in environment,
that you're only hunting an animal that's truly wild wild animal.
They can go wherever it wants.
So in order to harvest this animal,
you have to figure out how to get close enough to it.
You got to stock it,
you got a,
you know,
you gotta understand where the wind's blowing.
Like there's a lot of factors involved and when you take that animal,
most likely that animal would not have even known you existed until it died out
of nowhere.
It just dies and it's the most ethical way.
But that animal's still scared as fuck.
If it sees a person.
The reason banks is people like me that will shoot it
right now.
I see that.
Where's that bit?
You know,
just chilling out,
waiting to and has seen it.
It hasn't just seen his friends be slaughtered and hung up.
Yeah,
it's not trapped,
you know,
it's a wild animal.
You're going out and getting a wild animal,
but it's also wild animal.
That's most of the time they're aware of people and then they don't want to be
anywhere near us.
The real,
the real tripper is when you can go and you could see a wild animal that
probably never saw a fucking human being like go up to the Yukon or some shit
and then they freak out a,
they don't even know what the fuck you are.
A caribou.
Caribou will just look at you like,
what the fuck is this?
Sometimes antelopes will come towards people because they don't know what the
fuck they are.
Yeah.
They're like,
what the fuck are you?
I never seen one of you before.
And then
point blank.
Yeah.
Well not that close.
You just don't get that close,
but they will look at you.
But sometimes antelopes had encountered people and sometimes Caribou encounter
people and once they've encountered people they would get way touch here.
Yeah.
Do you have a catchphrase when you hunt?
When you hit one?
I need one.
Let's
Blam Blam we eat.
Inhale,
that's awesome.
That's the perfect one for pig hunting.
You know what I realized?
I realized a long time ago that cops and security guards do filler talk and they
do filler talk so that you won't talk to them.
So if a,
if a cop pulls you over and goes
a license and ID plays a license and registration please and then just sits
there.
You'll start going,
hey man,
what?
What,
what,
what I do,
or I was just keeping up the flow of traffic I wrote,
but instead they always come up and they go,
sir,
when I go need you do for me right now,
go ahead and get your license and registration out for me.
Okay?
Right now and meanwhile they're doing this kind of pattern.
That doesn't mean anything.
What I'm gonna need you to do for me right now is to go ahead and get your
license.
That doesn't mean anything other than license and registration.
They keep a nice sort of white noise buzz,
I should call it blue noise noise.
Cops make that stop you from going,
what?
What?
Hey,
I was just pulling out of my car like they don't want to hear that bullshit,
so they just keep that low grade talk going because it's only the cops that do
the for me right now and a lot of preamble into when I'm going to have to ask
you to do for me right now.
So go ahead and get your license and.
Okay.
Right now,
do you ever speak that way to anybody?
I mean if I wanted you to pass me the salt,
what I,
what I go Joe,
what I'm going to have to go ahead and do is ask you to pass me the salt.
Okay.
Right now.
Or when I just say pass me the salt,
I can't hang out with them anymore.
It's just too many words.
Oh Great.
I'm convinced they talked.
So you don't go.
What?
Why am I turning around?
Well,
what's this mean?
I didn't do anything.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
I totally understand.
But something that lasts for six hours.
So it seems like fuck boners that lasts for six hours.
We've talked about that.
All the problem.
It's a problem.
That's crazy.
Did you wear a fanny pack or something to like actually just took one last
night.
So I'm on it right now.
Or you
feel uncomfortable?
I'm amazed that you could feel comfortable over here.
No,
he's breathing.
So you're saying you went out last night or did you just stay home alone?
Sometimes you just want to let everybody know what's up.
I got a massage last night,
so I just did it before that
massage in quotes,
air quotes,
creeper.
It's just better that way.
Listen,
we were living in trying times.
He just wanted to fuck with the massage.
What an asshole fucking snake coming out of the top of past a turtle head.
What does that.
What is the
pink?
Well,
you know what?
We need to talk about everything.
That's the problem.
You can't just talk.
Only about passionate people.
Get bored of the same content for peaches over a number.
Then you brought up the boner.
Anyway,
listen,
I would bring it up to.
You're welcome.
If I was to check,
I'd been bringing up boners all day playing to me boners.
Do you know in the comments later?
I'd be like,
is it like,
does it give you like a whispery,
like whistling in your ears?
No,
the demon boners on its way between the worlds opens up just a creek and
spirits come flying through your fucking nervous system.
Spirits.
You feel them?
Yeah,
potentially.
I think that I was,
you know,
we're now discovering that it's good for so many things,
therapeutically for addictions,
for depression,
for ptsd and that sort of thing.
And that's all to the good.
But we shouldn't make the mistake of thinking Iowasca is only for sick people.
You know,
it's,
we're all wounded and we all need to understand something about our relationship
to nature,
potentially the paradigms that are emerging in Iowaska tourism or these more,
you know,
these.
I was centered spiritual communities in the states.
Potentially this has the,
uh,
this may transform mental health care in this country.
It may transform psychiatry and from that it might transform medicine and it
might actually transform all these other institutions that we have to deal with
whose values have become twisted over 2000 years of,
of bullshit and,
and indoctrination.
Uh,
you know,
these institutions are not going away and they're fine.
They just need to rediscover a moral dimension to the consequences of their
action,
if that makes any sense.
You know,
our cleverness far exceeds our wisdom and that's a problem.
That's the problem we've got to become wise.
And when we couple that with our ingenuity and our cleverness,
then we'll be on the way toward saving the planet,
saving ourselves.